i started a practice last year
each month of shooting a video where i
would recap what i did over the last
month and then talk a little bit about
what i what i hope to achieve in the
coming month
and since this is the january update i
thought that it would be a good time for
me to look back at the entire year
mostly about my youtube activities but
also about some of my other
professional work and to talk about
what's going on this year in 2014 we
have a lot of really interesting
projects lined up and i'll talk a bit
about those when i get to the 2014 part
but first i want to talk a little bit
about um
what happened during 2013 which which
turned out to be quite a big year um i i
continued teaching part-time at marist
college
and uh got quite a few videos shot for
my intro class and then quite a few for
the the ethics classes as well i'm
continuing to teach online for marist in
the
winter session and summer session as
well so i'm really teaching
close to a 3-3 load for them
and
i've done a lot of other stuff
the
the face-to-face teaching is just a
sliver of what i've been up to
so if we look at
youtube itself
i've shot um
in the last year or so i estimate
something like about
close to 130 140 videos
and i went and i i tallied them up there
were 70 core concept videos those short
you know 15 to 30 minute videos
about particular topics and uh that's
that's quite a few so i'm very happy
with that we're at about a little over a
hundred of those now if i remember right
and i i didn't get quite as much done on
the existentialism videos as i would
have liked to eventually you know it's
it's supposed to be a course of about a
hundred videos i added about another 15
of them but each one of those is an hour
so that's 15 hours more
of footage on heidegger and chest off
and
some other thinkers as well
i ended up shooting
somewhere around 13 or 14
personal videos mostly over the downtime
that i had which i'll talk about in a
few minutes
some of these were about particular
issues like being adopted or coping with
depression
or most recently
one about love and infatuation that i
shot for one of my students and quite a
few of these were about
my own philosophical development you
know i went through these stages like a
sart phase and a nietzsche phase and the
wittgenstein
phase and then there's also some
philosophers who uh
i i continue to be very interested in
like anselm and maurice blondell
so i shot quite a few of those
my intro classes
i recorded i think every single class
session so that added another 46 videos
to the
intro to philosophy
uh
course list
i think it's around 70 odd videos now so
70 hours of footage of intro to
philosophy focused on particular texts
more on ancient and medieval
than than modern or contemporary but
there's still some contemporary in there
and
what else
i recorded a number of different talks
that i that i did here and there
but i'll talk about that a little bit
more
i started doing these channel updates
and i think that that's something useful
i also started doing these these philoso
geek reflections on the technosphere
which is quite a mouthful i've shot four
of those so far and i plan to continue
those
and something else that i did towards
the end of the year that i i had a lot
of fun with and um there's a lot to to
to do in the coming year with
is using hangouts on here
and i thought that this is going to be
more or less like a regular google
hangout that people could like pop in
and pop out and i'd be able to see them
as it turns out that's not really the
case for hangouts on air you have to
have your your guest list so to speak
established ahead of time and then
invite people in so it's better for kind
of symposia or forum things or q a with
with somebody like like me who you know
produces content and
writes and talks
so that's what i did for the first one
we did it
not very well publicized one on on
socrates and even though we i think we
maybe put the event up just two days
before it it took place we had about 30
people come in
ask questions give comments and uh it
ran i originally wanted to run for about
an hour but we went about an hour and 20
minutes
um you can see the video i'll put a link
to it here with the annotation
and uh that was quite a bit of fun so i
think we're gonna we're gonna start
doing those fairly regularly i wanted to
do one of those
for new year's eve but unfortunately uh
both my wife and i were under the
weather
and um so we we decided to scratch that
but we're going to be doing quite a few
of them in the coming year
um
let's move on to talks so this is a good
year for talks
i gave quite a few of them in a number
of different venues
some of them at colleges and
universities
um some of them at conferences
i didn't record all of them with youtube
some of them i recorded as podcasts and
you can find them
to go to my my
my facebook page
i think i've got it listed there
i did a few radio shows
mostly internet radio
with
insight radio and with theology matters
i did i did three shows of theology
matters and two shows with insight radio
and those were sort of call-in
type of things you know
the insight radio about an hour and a
half of back and forth discussion that
was quite quite a lot of fun
and then the theology matters is
actually a two-hour show
first hour is me and the host talking
and then the second hour is actually
people calling in and i try to address
their questions or concerns or comments
as best as i can so that was a lot of
fun
um
what else happened in 2013 i guess one
one of the big bits of news was in june
out at the beach at montauk i damaged my
knee i tore two ligaments in my left
knee so that incapacitated me for quite
a while i wasn't up shooting the the
videos that i wanted to do until really
around august i started i started
shooting videos in front of the
chalkboard again i suppose getting the
chalkboard was was a bit of
news as well i'm not sure if we if we
bought it back uh
before the new year if we bought it
after the new year but i started using
it a lot this year and that was that was
quite helpful it made me no longer
dependent on finding a room that was
available or shooting videos in in
classes
i can shoot videos whenever whenever i
choose to now so that that's very
helpful
um
towards the end of this year my wife and
i started a program that the culinary
institute of america and and harvard
school of health are
doing as a joint venture
um and it's it's or it's sort of this
holistic idea that that's you know
combined with exercise and cooking
classes
and you know how to carry out
substitutions with foods to make them
more more healthy uh not only you know
in terms of calories but in terms of you
know providing you what you need over
the day and connected with mindfulness
training
and health coaching and they're rolling
all these things into one big shebang
and so we we got into that and uh we're
involved with it
um i'm trying to lose some some weight
and get back into
some some decent condition and also
rehab the knee uh prior to the surgery
that i'll have to have done on it which
i'm not looking forward to this year
as a matter of fact if i could find some
way to get out of that altogether i
probably would
what else i got some writing done
published a few pieces here and there
um
if i remember right some of the
encyclopedia articles that i'd written
for the new
uh supplement of the catholic
encyclopedia came out on stoicism the
unconscious and 19th century philosophy
and i've got a piece on aristotle
and some phenomenologists coming out in
a book
really i think that came out this this
fall i didn't do as much writing as i
would have liked to and i didn't do as
much publishing but i think that's in
part because i spent so much time
uh in the classroom
shooting videos in meetings
writing content that sort of thing
i spent a lot of time building
my online presence and
not just as as gregory sadler you know
the sort of philosophy guy but also
with the company that that my wife and i
use as our umbrella for for these
activities reason i owe reason it out
and
so i spent quite a bit of
time and energy and effort sort of
consistently putting in
uh content and engaging with with
with people on these these online forums
interestingly
most of my work didn't happen on the
ones that are devoted to
philosophy like the american association
for philosophy teachers or the full you
know the
public philosophy network because those
really aren't doing that much right now
surprisingly
they're just starting to to get moving
instead it's been
i would say
in two main areas one has to do with
social networks
and one has to do with educational
platforms and they kind of overlap a bit
you know youtube has youtube edu and i'm
in there
and along with like yale courses and
european graduate school my videos are
probably about
at least with the philosophy and even
some of the
the uh literature stuff probably about a
good 20 to 30 percent of some of the
things that they they offer
um so
let me talk about the
the online course stuff first
i got into a lot of conversations or
rather we got into a lot of
conversations my wife and i my partner
in reason io
with a number of different online
educational platforms and so we're now
at the point where we're
because of the youtube content and
because of some of the other things that
we've been doing
we're actually getting courted by
startup companies that want to
bust into the educational marketplace
that what i've been calling the
technosphere
and really make an impact and every
single one of them
claims that they're gonna like you know
revolutionize education
um you know from the from the ground up
i don't think that's gonna happen but i
think that they are
offering a lot of lifelong learners a
lot of students a lot of people who want
to do
you know additional
brush up study people who are even
college professors themselves and like
to know something more about that i
think that they're offering a lot of
great educational
resources and forums and communities to
people who wouldn't ordinarily have have
that access
so
over the last year the two that i've
been involved with the most have been
curious
which is just starting to pick up steam
now and
uh learnest
learnest everything on there is for free
and you create these these complex
learnings they're they're called and
boards it's kind of like pinterest but
but educational
uh curious some of the things are free
some of them you pay a very nominal fee
for like a buck or two bucks
and you you get access to to lessons
that people are producing there's video
content there's
written content there's links to
textbooks that you you know you might
find useful there's quizzes there's
handouts there's all sorts of cool stuff
like that
and then i uh towards the end of the
year i got involved with a company
called opperno which is doing things on
a much grander scale so i'll talk about
that in a little while let me come back
to social networks
so i'm involved in a lot of social
networks um and have been for
about i don't know four or five years
and i i find some of them more useful
than others and i admittedly put in more
more effort and more work on some than
others
but i i try to post regularly on all of
them and interact with with people and
get content that that's interesting or
valuable from them so i'm on linkedin
this year i passed the
sort of milestone of the 500 contacts
thing once you've got 500 contacts just
says 500 plus
and i'm now at the point where
i'm getting a lot of interesting
requests to to collaborate
through that um
google plus i started using a bit more i
still don't use it quite as much as i
use my facebook page but uh with the
interface with youtube i think it's it's
becoming
very useful i suppose you could say that
i actually am using google plus a lot
more than i think i am because
of the uh
the
roll-in of youtube comments into google
plus
so there's that i use twitter um not as
much as i i
did in the past
um
but i i check on it just about at least
once a day
i also use pinterest um
that's
not quite as social really when you get
down to it but it's kind of cool for
being able to post images of things in
links
academia.edu
if you're not using academia.edu and you
are involved in academics you probably
should get an academia.edu because
this was the year where they really hit
critical mass
and it's this even if you're not an
academic and you like getting access to
free
articles or handouts or teaching
documents
it has become the place to go for that
sort of stuff and you can you can see
what people are into and they they post
their research they post some of them
actually can blog on it
i'm also involved with goodreads but i
haven't done that much with with
goodreads this this last year
that's that's
more for oriented towards uh the
bibliophile public where i put a lot of
my effort has been facebook i have a
facebook author page
and
i gained about
550 new
likes or subscribers to that which
more than doubled the the amount of
people that i i'm connected with on that
so that's kind of cool
and i i you know i post my videos on
there and i'll post some reflections on
there uh maybe once a day or so and if i
see an interesting link you know to an
article in the atlantic or the guardian
or you know what have you i i do that
usually along with some comments and
then sometimes we get some good
discussions
um all that kind of pales in comparison
to to youtube
with youtube
i just went and looked at my my
information uh today
so in 2013
on this this youtube channel
we had half a million views
so
now a lot of that's repeat right people
going in more than once
but half a million people at one time or
another
looked at one of these these videos
um
people watched five million minutes of
the video footage that i've uploaded
that's really interesting i mean this is
this is academic philosophy stuff this
is not you know
funny cats videos or
stuff about contemporary culture and
what's going on with with you know miley
cyrus or
something like that it's not music
videos we don't have any sound tracks to
our stuff it's very low tech
you know we have backdrops that are
bookshelves and we had
five million
uh
minutes
watched people
paying attention to these these great
texts and thinkers and
and hopefully
this is one of the things that we
unfortunately can't track
i would love to to know
how many people
read things
because of
hearing about it on on the channel
and how many minutes were devoted to
reading texts
as opposed to to watching videos that
would be really that would be really
cool information have but of course you
know youtube has absolutely no way of
tracking that and i think that if we
gave google the power to track that with
google glass that would probably be a
bad idea
um what else we had
uh 6500 so 6500
new subscribers we
basically tripled
no more than tripled we we
quadrupled the the number of people
subscribed to this channel who get the
updates get these get these feeds
there were
no i i have no way of telling how many
of these were my own comments because i
try to respond to
comments as often as i can
there were 6 800 comments on these these
videos in this channel over the last
year and i'm guessing that probably at
least 2 000 of those
were me responding to other people's
comments because i try to remain engaged
with with my my viewers
i'm spending now about half an hour to
an hour each day addressing
uh subscriptions emails comments it's
it's starting to become quite a time
intensive
um
so that was uh that was 2013. uh it was
it was a really good year and
things are growing um we're starting to
get a lot of traction this is this is a
lot of fun putting out this this
information into the
the techno sphere and seeing what people
do with it
2014 we've got some even bigger things
planned so
let me talk about youtube first
we're going to do more hangouts on air i
think we're going to try to do this
monthly and
i'm going to shoot for doing the next
hangout on air
next saturday so
today is the third that means that
fourth that'll be the 11th of
uh january 2014. i'll put some more
information about that
uh you can find it in my google plus
there'll be an event page you can find
it my facebook page and i'll also put
something on youtube about it
um
we're going to have
topics for these these these hangouts
and i'll i'll try to announce them in
advance
some of them are just going to be me
doing q a with viewers and some of them
i'm going to have guests
and we're going to discuss a topic and
then we're going to do some some q a
with viewers as well so it's going to be
kind of like a
philosophy show you might say
sometimes it'll be more like a
author meets
uh
not necessarily critics but
readers
sometimes it'll be more like a a
symposium or a panel
and then we'll open it up to questions
and answers so that we're going to be
doing that
um got a lot more existentialism videos
lined up i'm going to be starting to
shoot them today
starting out with some heidegger
actually uh next one coming up is
heidegger's question concerning
technology and i might have to do that
as two videos depending on how much time
it takes me to get through that
um we're going to be doing some kafka
some some gabriel marcel some more uh
rainier maria rilke
and
then we're gonna you know try to get
back to some of the other thinkers who
we we touched on but didn't uh didn't
fully flesh out like dostoyevsky we're
going to do some more nietzsche some
more kierkegaard some more camus some
more sart we're also going to do some uh
simone de beauvoir we haven't done we're
going to do some ortega gossip we
haven't done
uh some jaspers if i can get to it uh
maybe martin buber
and
who else tillick if if we have the time
jacques marita he has a nice little
piece where he tries to
flesh out what what existentialism would
mean for a thomas so so all that's going
to be coming up over the next year
uh the other thing that's kind of big
news is
going to be shooting a sequence and i
have no idea how long it's going to take
me or how many videos this is going to
comprise and we're going to go through
the entirety of hegel's phenomenology of
spirit beginning with preface
and ending with absolute knowledge
and everything in between we're not
going to skip over any of the parts
i may give some things a little less
attention but you know with this book
everybody wants to read it for the
master slave dialectic which is which is
really
just this far in right
and
the really interesting stuff comes later
on throughout the rest of this so
so i'm going to be shooting these i'm
going to try to get maybe
one or two done a week
and if i if i do that we'll have quite a
few videos on the phenomenology spirit
so i'm really looking forward to that
um
one of the things i've wanted to do for
quite a while is to shoot a sequence of
videos basically like a course
on descartes meditations
and go through each of the meditations
one by one
not like what we do in an intro class
but really go through them
uh and then look at the objections to
the meditations because there were some
big heavy hitter philosophers like
thomas hobbes and pierre gascendy who
were giving these objections to the
meditations and then look at descartes
replies so that's going to be that's
probably going to take a good
15 videos i think to get through
hour-long videos
i need to finish aristotle's categories
i've had that hanging out there for
quite a while i think that's an
important text
to
to work one's way through because
there's a lot of aristotelian
metaphysics rolled up in there and i
think it could be very helpful for for
beginners to have that
we're going to keep shooting core
concept videos those shorter videos i'm
going to keep on shooting the personal
videos from time to time when i've got
the time
i'm going to keep on shooting the
philoso geek reflections videos because
there's a lot of interesting stuff
uh yet to explore with with the
technosphere that we now live in
and i'm also going to be doing a course
for marist college that
i haven't
done for them before i used to teach it
when i worked for ball state pretty
regularly really actually every semester
sometimes two sections
called religion in american culture it's
called religion in america
uh
at marist but it's basically the same
sort of thing it's talking about
the history of the united states
and
all the different religious groups that
have been involved with with it and and
have have affected politics and culture
and even geography to a certain extent
um
and so in in a large respect you could
think of it as both a history class like
charting forward progress as far close
to the present as we can but you could
also think of it as sort of a survey
class going over all these different
religious
groups and saying well what are these
what do these people believe and where
did they come from what's their their
background what's their history what do
they think about these other groups
and we're doing it from a religious
studies perspective which means that
there's no faith commitments required
the goal is not to proselytize or or
convince anybody of anything
it's rather to produce understanding
which is something that you can in fact
measure by you know assessing students
on that
so i'm going to be shooting
videos for that
in part because my my students benefit
from from having the course videos
available to them they can always go
back over the material
and in part so i can use it to develop
online classes uh based on the same
content later on
and
in part because i think people
you know and my viewership might be
interested in that
so
i'll put uh
put a link to what the textbook is going
to be in case you're interested in it
class is actually going to start the
22nd of january
and i'll be uploading videos from from
that point on
not the first class because that's the
go over all the syllabus
get everybody to sign the release kind
of thing but then from that point on
we're going to be doing it
um
we got a lot of speaking engagements
lined up for the the new year which i'm
really happy about
uh one of the things i'm going to be
talking about i think quite a bit will
be the
seven deadly sins
uh there i touched on that a bit in a
talk that i did at marist
last semester
where i only got to talk about it for an
hour there's a lot of other interesting
things i'm going to focus in
specifically on particular
you know representations or discussions
of say gluttony what does that actually
consist in you know like for instance
the monks thought that you had to get
gluttony down or you didn't have a
prayer of getting any other
advice taken care of if you if you
couldn't handle gluttony um there's a
number of other
topics that are connected with that like
artistic depictions of the sins and
what's going on with this iconography
through the ages
and how are they depicted in you know
this poet's work and in this poet's work
and why do we have such a impoverished
conception of them
in the presence so there's a lot of
material to talk about i'll be you know
doing
some you know closely focused things on
what alkene thought about these or what
thomas aquinas thought about these or
what gregory the great thought about
these or you know how
john of the cross transformed these into
the spiritual
uh sins you know having to do with the
interior life and things like that so
that's gonna be a lot of fun uh that
that's only a bit of the talks that
we've got going on we've got some some
workshops and development um
some of these things have to do more
with practical reasoning i've got a few
proposals and and papers out there under
review
so i don't know which conferences i'll
actually be going to at this point over
the coming year because the way it works
in academia is you send out a proposal
and either it gets accepted and they say
all right you're in the conference or it
gets rejected and they say no you're
definitely out or they say well we'd
like you to tweak it a bit
and then you know it's up to you whether
you want to conform to what they want
so i've got a few things like that going
on uh i don't know what what exactly
i'll be presenting on but i know i'll be
going to some of these
conferences i'll continue doing the
radio shows so long as they they want me
to do them on the inside radio and
theology matters and i might be doing a
few
other radio related items we're in some
talks about that
um
i'm thinking about starting
quarterly
face-to-face
meetups in the local area i'm i'm in the
hudson valley in new york
so
you know we're thinking about doing
things
in this area or perhaps
down in the city
once every quarter so you know one
during january through march 1
april through through june you know and
so on
i think it'd be kind of cool to meet up
with the people who are enjoying the
videos
i've done
i've done this at an individual level
before but i've never done this at a
group level so it's kind of an
experiment we'll see how that
goes um
what else
oh
i should put in a plug here we we
actually have
online forms
through reason io
that that we've developed or actually my
wife has developed because she's one who
has these these skills
if you're interested in booking me for a
talk
or suggesting that some organization
booked me for a talk we have forms that
you can actually
download and fill in
and then send to
the organization and say hey you know i
like this guy
um i've seen his his work before i think
you should book him for a talk you know
here's his contact information so we
have forms that can do that we also have
a fillable form online where reason io
can can transfer that that sort of stuff
for you
um so that's that's it about speaking
stuff
uh what else we've got some online stuff
coming up that is very exciting so i
mentioned a player know before
uh aplerno
is doing what some of these other online
educational
formats are or programs or platforms are
doing but they're doing it at a higher
level
they're actually seeking accreditation
so
courses that would be offered for
college credit
and they invited me and a number of
other
instructors who they they
whose work they'd seen and who they
liked to submit course proposals to go
through their their
orientation process to produce online
courses that will be offered for credit
and i'm happy to say that they approved
my introduction to existentialism course
which is going to use some of the
the videos that i've shot so far in the
existentialism sequence
i'm going to be supplementing it with a
lot of other materials developing
modules for for the students quizzes
writing assignments they're going to be
sort of like weekly online meetups where
it's going to be q a and discussion
about existentialism and these key
thinkers we're going to be looking at
about um
12 or 13 different thinkers over the
course of a 12-week semester
and it is going to cost something but
the
plairno is keeping the cost pretty low
it's it's a way for instructors like me
to sort of freelance
and to
be able to earn enough money
to perhaps do this sort of thing
full-time
so i'm really excited about this it's
it's a way to offer really interesting
courses to people who really want to be
there in that online classroom
i'll give more information about that as
as things roll out right now playernow
is still involved with the process of
accreditation but it looks like things
should be
on track about uh mid-march
so that that's really exciting
um
still teaching stuff from marist of
course
uh i'm gonna be doing more with curious
i'm going to upload a number of lessons
beginning with a free one on on uh
plato or rather socrates apology a bunch
of free lessons on that i have some
stuff on sart so far and then i'm going
to start uploading some some lessons
that'll actually cost a minimal amount
to do but they'll have all sorts of cool
things cool features like
quizzes and handouts and uh
yeah you know the sort of thing that you
expect of the course
i'm going to keep learning i'm going to
keep adding things to my learnest
courses those are kind of nice they use
the youtube videos and they use
documents that i upload in
academia.edu and then they linked
encyclopedia articles and things like
that
i'm looking at teachers pay teachers and
at udemy if i have the time i will be
posting things on those
those are you know where you can offer
educational resources or or courses or
lessons
um but we'll see we're also working
through reason io right now
to develop some
some courses of our own through some
other uh web-based platforms but i don't
want to talk too much about that until
we actually get the stuff up i you know
it's kind of like putting on a
promissory note and i like to
deliver before i
before i start making too many promises
uh the last thing that i i'm going to be
doing which is really exciting
some of it is just sort of continuing
the process of what i've been doing the
last couple years you know the academic
writing i have a number of papers that
it need to be
polished up and sent out to journals i
just have been behind in that
i'm still working on the aristotle and
anger book i'm still working on the
anselm and moral theory book i'm still
translating anselm's day similar to
nibbus
but i've also i'm involved in a textbook
proposal i can't talk that much about it
at this stage because um
it's it's still in development but it's
going to be a really
cool uh
idea that that's being worked out i can
say this that it has to do with ancient
philosophy
and it's looking at it in a somewhat
different lens
and if if this comes off it's going to
be a really cool way to offer
ancient thought
to undergraduates
and
we decided that we're going to start
doing some self-publishing as well not
just white papers like i've done in the
past but actual books
these are going to be a bit a bit
smaller scale they're going to be a bit
shorter they're going to be
written to a more popular audience
and we're going to self-publish them
we're not quite sure
exactly whether we're going to do with
amazon or with some other
venue at this point but but i've got
three ideas that i want to
to work out this this year so this is
kind of ambitious one of them
and it's one of my my viewers who
suggested this and it's a great idea
i've got all these core concept videos
um why not put together something like
an ebook
that would take all these core concept
videos and have the video there
and then have you know sort of like a
one or two page discussion of what we're
talking about in the video maybe a few
you know like uh
uh relevant passages from the text that
we're talking about
um
links to any useful
resources that are there
and just bundle these together into
you know
like 30 videos at a time
so i think that's a great idea and i'm
going to try doing at least one of those
i think the place to start of course is
with
the ancient philosophy because you know
why begin at the end why not start at
the beginning with uh with plato so what
that means is i probably need to shoot a
lot more plato core concept videos early
on um
one of the things that that i've been
here's another project one of the things
that i've been involved with over the
last couple years is students
and lifelong learners writing me and
saying hey i want to study philosophy
i've got no idea where i should go or
how i should begin this you know there's
so much stuff out there
what should i do
and my advice has always been well start
with plato because you know you're not
going to go wrong and you're going to
learn something
and it's kind of important to get get
some plato down before you tackle a lot
of other things
but people have been looking for more
structured
work more structured approaches to this
and what i'm going to do
is write something like a guide to
self-study in in philosophy
and put that out there
and it is going to begin with plato for
the most part um
i got to put a lot of thought into this
exactly how how i would do this how i
would suggest this
but i think that there's a
demand for that i think there's a lot of
people who
who want that sort of thing i think that
a lot of the people who want that sort
of thing
um really
maybe what they want is is not so much
somebody just to say here's what you got
to do this this this and this they're
looking for somebody to say
here's here's some ideas and then they
can say oh yeah that was more or less
what i thought i would do but now
they've got some confirmation and it
gives them a bit more confidence when
they're when they're doing it so that's
what i that's one of the projects
and then one of the things that i've
been wanting to do for a while so the
third third shorter book project
it's coming from my teaching ethics
classes for so many years
students come up with a lot of cool
examples and i i give them examples to
chew on as well and they they come up
with interesting takes on them so you
know if you think about how to apply
kant's categorical imperative and what
you know what would be some examples of
when things go wrong
and say treating somebody as a means and
not not as an end
there's all sorts of examples and you
know you've got kant's classic examples
but think about our contemporary life
you know one of the ones that comes up
from my students every single semester
is it okay to use my contacts for me to
compete to get a job
even if that means that
i beat out other people
how would the how would kant view that
using the categorical imperative and
then how would aristotle do that how
would jon stewart mill view that
these are some some really
interesting cases and and i've been you
know seeing these come up semester after
semester and discussing them with
students
so i think that there would be a market
not only for people that are studying
ethics or interested in in thinking
about these sort of things
but even for like
beginning level instructors to have
something
from somebody who's been teaching for 15
years saying
here's some stuff that you can
definitely get your students interested
in and here's how you would tackle it
here's what so-and-so would say here's
what so-and-so would say
try it out
i think that could be very useful for
people doing business ethics as well you
know who often times
you know might be in like the human
resources department and they don't
actually have a lot of training in
ethics
to have you know some something designed
by somebody who actually knows the field
uh who says here's you know here's
something you can actually use as a
resource
so that's an awful lot to to get done
but we're talking about a year so if i
just stick with it i think that all
these things are are possible
and we're
really looking forward to 2014 i think
that that uh what's been going on up
till this point in 2013 and 2012 and in
2011 when i was still at
fayetteville state before i
moved up
all that was with some good building and
some good momentum and now 2014 is going
to be
a very exciting year